[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir juste avant de commencer
je tenais aussi à remercier les
personnes qui sont venus aujourd'hui les
autres participants du concours je sais
qu'il y en a parmi vous qui sont arrivés
qui sont venus merci d encore
juste avant de commencer j'ai une petite
question à vous lancer à vous poser une
question personnelle si pendant cette
petite courte pause vous étiez sur teen
d'heure
et que potentiellement vous avez vu mon
profil
sachez que c'est vraiment mon profil est
ce que j'aimerais que vous fassiez cessé
de m'envoyer un premier message
parce que j'ai pas l'habitude de le
faire mais disons que là ce soir à
l'heure actuelle c'est un peu compliqué
je suis totalement en train de vous
mentir puisque envoyer un message c'est
pas vraiment le premier réflexe que je
fais quand je viens de match et une
nouvelle personne
justo le cas
je vous entends rire ne blâmez pas je
pense que je suis loin d'être le seul à
le faire
pour les personnes qui sont peu perdu
avec mon anglicismes un peu approximatif
ou même ceux qui ne sont pas forcément
familiers avec les applications de
rencontres match et c'est l'idée ou deux
personnes démontre un intérêt mutuel on
dit qu'il ya une correspondance et ce
talk et c'est l'idée de chercher des
informations complémentaires sur une
personne d'enquêté si je peux reprendre
le thème du soir
que vous une personne que vous
connaissez ou pas d'ailleurs ce peut
être votre ex par exemple
mais j'ai envie de vous dire que dans
cette situation précise
stall qui a son intérêt tout simplement
pour savoir si on ne tombe pas face un
criminel déjà ou une arnaque
et sur ce point j'aimerais qu'on salue
tous ensemble mon petit monde qui ne se
reconnaîtra que trop bien
pour les personnes qui ne reconnaissent
pas je vous invite à regarder un
documentaire qui justement parle d'un
d'une arnaque en fait finalement sur les
applications de rencontres
très bien face à ça j'ai souvent
plusieurs réactions différentes on a les
personnes qui savent très bien de quoi
je parle on a des experts je pense avec
nous ce soir je porte de stockage on a
des personnes qui savent à peu près ce
que c'est qu'ils voient très rapidement
et des personnes qui ne savent pas du
tout ce que c'est
et fervent défenseur de l'égalité ce
soir par chance je suis de bonjour j'ai
décidé de vous montrer comment juste olc
et pour ce faire
je vous propose une petite mise en
situation imaginons que nous soyons tous
ensemble une seule et même personne que
nous aurons dans ce téléphone nous
ouvrons notre application de rencontre
et vous tomberez on pompe du coup sûr se
profile
qu'est ce qu'on fait déjà en swype à
droite pour montrer son intérêt pour la
personne parce que demain pourquoi pas
les deux 2 ça risquerait de compromettre
la suite de la démonstration dont je
vous laisse pas vraiment le choix
et finalement on retrouve quelques
similitudes avec la photo précédente des
lunettes des cheveux en arrière et on
aimerait surtout éviter de réitérer
l'erreur qu'a pu subir les jeunes filles
juste avant et pour ce faire imaginons
que que nous avons discuté avec cette
personne et que nous prévoyons un
rencard ce soir prenons nos
prédispositions
enquêtons sur la personne qu'avons nous
en face de nous une photo bon maintenant
je sais qu'on peut rechercher par photos
sur google mais c'est un peu difficile
pour vous montrer ce soir mais à part ça
on a aussi un prénom on à l'université
de paris dauphine et on à paris sur ces
informations là les informations les
plus ciblés on a donc bien évidemment le
prénom on pourrait prendre paris mais
disons que paris dauphine c'est un peu
plus précis je vous propose de vous
vêtir de votre meilleure tenue de
charlot comme des temps modernes et
cherchons sur internet des informations
en tapant simplement son prénom est
dauphine
on a en premier la ligne dean ce que
c'est étonnant pour un étudiant de
dauphine je ne pense pas on a son nom de
famille super survolons le lien très
rapidement une photo de profil pourquoi
pas ça va nous aider à visualiser la
personne en vision 360 ça peut être très
important pour certaines personnes
assistant à maîtrise d ouvrage axa
banque ok levallois-perret une banlieue
pas piquée des hannetons a priori
rappelons que ce soir on est encore dans
cette situation on a un rencard avec
cette personne il se dit informaticiens
communicants super on aura de la
discussion ce soir j'espère qu'on ne
parlerait pas que de haine ft par la
suite on a beau quelque chose d'un peu
plus fun ouvert au monde de l'eau nos
logis du sport de décembre un bon vivant
très clean on va dire c'est basique sur
un profil linkedin axa allianz edf
toujours très cliché d'un étudiants de
dauphine on voit aussi qu'il a été dans
le ciné gomba t il à l'entrée déchire
les tickets oui j'ai aussi permis
d'assister aux raisins des grains une
nouvelle fois dans la soirée
on a aussi quelques missions par-ci
par-là vendeurs hockey et avec le
parcours scolaire on apprend qu'il n'est
pas parisien mais sudiste en espérant
qu'il ait gardé l'accent du sud
france est bien sûr indonésien anglais
bon bla bla bla bla bla bla tout ce
qu'on peut trouver sur linkedin
finalement
après tout ça on peut aller aussi voir
sur le deuxième lien et on est content
et on est ravi de savoir qui donne aussi
des cours de mathématiques
et à la lecture on est ravi qui ne donne
pas de cours de français à la vue du
nombre de fautes d'orthographe sur
quatre lignes ça fait peur mais disons
que sur la petite description
il nous donne une master class sur la
réussite
la clé de la réussite c'est la
compréhension
et pour comprendre il faut en son sens
saisir ce qu'on n'a pas compris
ou si vous êtes perdus très philosophe à
ses heures perdues en sachant que c'est
un comble pour la personne puisque la
personne qui a écrit ces quelques lignes
la a eu un sur 20 au baccalauréat de
philosophie mais bon passons
non il n'a pas écrit que son prénom oui
il a écrit deux pages il n'a toujours
pas de réponse sur le pourquoi du
comment de ce 1 sur 20 on peut lancer un
message encore ce soir on apprend aussi
qu'il a une petite soeur très bien
troisième lien un lien youtube racontant
son parcours scolaire complexes jusqu'à
paris alors je vous spoilé 20 minutes
mais complexe on parlera surtout de
réorientation profonde réorientation
scolaire tout simplement mais j'ai
appris a pas longtemps en discutant avec
des amis que la voie était aussi très
importante dans le milieu de la
séduction donc ça peut être aussi une
opportunité pour découvrir sa voix en
avant première avant même que l'on
rencontre ce soir rappelons on a encore
un record ce soir avec cette personne on
a son nom de famille pourquoi s'en
priver tapons du coup son nom et son
prénom qui me semble presque plus ciblé
que avant et découvrons ensemble
un lien linkedin que nous avons déjà
survolé une chaîne youtube je vous
spoiler enquête il ya zéro vidéo dessus
un lien d'un réseau social qui ne
souhaiterait peut-être pas abordé ce
soir mais disons que pour sa défense il
avait besoin de se divertir à une
période de sa vie alors attendez voilà à
une période de sa vie qui était un peu
difficile pour nous tous je crois
s'en suit très rapidement d'une mention
dans le journal de l'université de paris
en tant que président du bda en espérant
qu'il n'est pas légaux qui va avec
pourquoi pas et s'en suit du coup de
quelques articles en italien puisque
évidemment le prénom à consonance
italienne et on ne s'en doute pas quand
on voit le personnage
on pourrait s'arrêter là on a pas mal
d'informations déjà
mais ne dit on pas que le meilleur
endroit pour cacher encore
si la deuxième page de google
et nous sommes ravis
de pouvoir retrouver une page facebook
est une page instagram j'attire votre
attention sur le fait que la page
facebook et le profil instagram ne sont
pas référencées directement sur son
profil mais par le fait que son
entourage les mentionner
pour terminer très rapidement on voit
une mention de son prêt non dans la
liste des élèves de inscrit deux niveaux
première au lycée claude nougaro en
occitanie
et donc ça confirme du coup le profil
linkedin que nous venons de voir et
enfin le résultat au baccalauréat sans
la note de philo
très bien à ce moment je pense que c'est
le point culminant de la surprise si je
vous annonce que la personne que nous
venons de ce talk et ce soir n'est autre
que moi même
bonsoir enchanté je pense que je n'ai
pas besoin de présenter davantage vous
en savez déjà peut-être un peu trop
enfin bon à travers cette petite
exercice de quelques minutes nous nous
sommes aperçus d'une chose c'est qu'à
travers le très peu d'informations que
nous avons en soi juste le prénom +
dauphine en d'autres termes les seules
informations que vous détenez de moi ce
soir nous avons pu collecter pas mal
d'informations le concernant déjà pour
savoir que je ne suis pas un criminel
et à travers ça bon après je le conçois
mon prénom est très peu commun ce qui a
plutôt favorisé le référencement sur
google mais disons que j'ai compris une
chose c'est que ma trace numérique était
plus conséquente que ce que je ne
l'imaginais
alors vous avez sûrement vous posez la
question même si je pense que vous avez
une petite idée de ce que c'est la trace
numérique mais la trace numérique ce
sont un ensemble d'informations que vous
laissez de manière consciente ou
inconsciente de manière active ou
passive donc consciente à travers par
exemple et publications sur les réseaux
sociaux facebook instagram linkedin mais
aussi passive comme par exemple mon
baccalauréat je n'avais aucune idée qu
on pouvait retrouver mon baccalauréat du
coup sûr sur internet où les mentions à
travers le journal de l'université etc
etc
ok donc face à cette information là ce
que je vous propose de faire c'est que
nous prenions l'air dans un premier
temps analysons la situation oui
effectivement notre trace numérique est
plus conséquente que ce que l'on imagine
ce que je vous ai démontré ce sont
l'étendue du possible en tant que
particulier comme vous et moi ce qu'on
ne peut chercher sur google mais savez
vous que les grandes structures telles
que votre nice heures d'accès internet
ou même les admins des réseaux des
établissements de votre travail ou même
l'université si vous connecter à leurs
réseaux ont la quasi totalité accès à
toutes vos informations que vous lisez
sur internet réglementer certes mais
exhaustive
et je ne parle même pas des petits
fichiers par site internet qu'il se
laisse à travers des petites
informations telles que si vous passé
tant de temps sur un produit
tentant sur cette page si vous naviguez
si vous authentifier
que vous acceptez très souvent ces
petits fichiers que vous connaissez
sûrement sous le nom de cookies
en bref à ce jour nous avons tous les
outils à notre disposition pour pouvoir
enquêter sur chacun d'entre vous
alors j'ai peut-être fait quelques
raccourcis mais disons que malgré toutes
les prédispositions que vous preniez que
ce soit la navigation privée oui alors
j'espère ne pas casser un mythe si je
vous dis que la navigation privée que
vous utilisez dans votre navigateur
n'est pas forcément privées partout elle
n'est privé que sur votre appareil c'est
à dire que du coup on a quand même fait
que ça votre historique si on doit
remonter du coup à votre fournisseur
d'accès internet par exemple
mais tout ça pour vous dire que malgré
tout les précaires prédispositions que
l'on peut prendre on peut toujours
enquêter sur vous
face à cette information je vous propose
encore de prendre du recul et
interprétant là il est vrai que cela
peut faire peur de se dire que une
partie de notre identité peut nous
échapper des mains
mais même si aujourd'hui à l'heure
actuelle on peut compter avec de grandes
gouvernance et des institutions telles
que la rgpp ou la cnil qui nous protège
en tant que données personnelles
on a à ce jour une inquiétude sur le
fait que notre identité peut nous
échapper des mains
on peut aussi compter sur le droit ou
des référencements si par exemple vous
les enlevez un lien sur les moteurs de
recherche que le lien pas le contenu
internet bien évidemment mais quel lien
mais au-delà de ça
aujourd'hui on pourrait se poser la
question de si on peut toujours passer
totalement incognito informatiquement je
ne parle pas que des réseaux sociaux car
il s'agirait simplement d'arrêter de les
utiliser ou se mettre en privé quoique
se mettre en privé on a bien vu que du
coup on pouvait retrouver mes réseaux
sociaux
mais au-delà de ça je parle de
l'utilisation d'internet en général
pour se déplacer pour réserver une table
ou un rendez vous médical comme on a vu
passer longtemps
nous avons aujourd'hui ce besoin de
créer un compte voire même nous
authentifiée
alors je le conçois on peut toujours
faire sans aujourd'hui c'est à dire
qu'on peut on peut téléphoner levé la
main pour appeler un taxi par exemple
mais seriez-vous prêt à attendre dans le
froid à 3 heures du matin seriez vous
prêt à attendre de longues minutes au
téléphone tout ça pour vous dire que
votre prochain rendez vous chez
l'ophtalmo c'est dans trois mois
je pense qu'on peut tous accordés à dire
que finalement l'internet nous a pas mal
faciliter la vie et personnellement en
tant qu'étudiant du 21e siècle
je ne peux que très difficilement
concevoir
chercher un emploi pour octobre 2022 oui
je fais passer un message je me permets
je peux très difficilement concevoir
l'idée de pouvoir construire de créer
voire de créer des opportunités comme on
le fait ce soir
je pense qu'on a une attaque partiel sur
le sujet il est important de se poser la
question bien sûr de la gravité de
savoir si on peut toujours passer
incognito de savoir quels sont
finalement les actions à mener mais
au-delà de ça en tant que diplomate est
plutôt optimiste je pense qu'il ya un
juste milieu à faire on peut trouver un
juste milieu peut-on faire autrement
face à cette action la dernière action
du coup la réaction quoi faire dans un
premier temps maîtrisée le maîtrisable
comme par exemple supprimer un compte
super prof bourré de fautes surtout
maîtriser le maîtrisable c'est
finalement maîtriser l'aspect active de
la trace numérique
prendre conscience que nous sommes aussi
en partie
maîtres de notre identité digitale
voire même pour les plus aventureux
d'entre nous l'utiliser en tant que
meilleur allié pourquoi pas notre
vitrine de notre personnalité aussi bien
professionnellement sur linkedin ou même
sur instagram personnellement ou
facebook
ça peut être un lieu de libre échange de
nos centres d'intérêt et de montrer
finalement notre vitrine une autre
partie notre personnalité qu'on n'aurait
pas forcément eu le temps de le
présenter à l'heure normale ou en temps
réel
dans un deuxième temps
l'aspect pas si finalement
j'ai une bonne nouvelle pour vous ce
soir nous avons déjà maîtrisé la moitié
nous avons déjà fait même la moitié du
chemin sur la gestion de cette trace
numérique passive en y posant des mots
en ayant conscience de son existence
aujourd'hui avec la rgpp la cnil nous
sommes dans cet esprit de
consentement
partout sur internet vous trouverez des
informations sur comment collecte des
données comment ils les utilisent et
comme il est très tôt ses écrits
peut-être en police 3 tout en bas mais
c'est à vous d'enquêté
je ne prétends pas avoir la bible des
bonnes pratiques ni même la vérité
absolue sur le sujet mais disons que
ce que je vous propose de faire ce soir
c'est qu'à l'issue de notre discussion
quand vous rentrerez chez vous preniez
votre téléphone ou internet moteur de
recherche vous taper votre nom votre
prénom mais pas que taper aussi votre
lieu de travail votre lieu d'études
quelques informations par ci par là et
vous serez étonné peut-être du nombre
d'informations que l'on peut récolter
sur vous mais face à ça ce que je vous
propose dernière proposition
c'est qu'ensemble
prenons l'air
merci
[Applaudissements]